a song that foreshadows a major twist
and a fun connection to wonder woman
with a complex plot that includes plenty
of stunning reveals there's a lot more
going on in Heart of Stone than meets
the eye spoilers ahead
like any great action movie Heart of
Stone opens with its hero in the middle
of a dangerous Mission little do we know
however that computer expert Rachel
Stone isn't even a real MI6 operative
but is working undercover as one for the
enigmatic Global intelligence agency
known as the charter in this role she
goes behind the back of her MI6 team and
takes on an entire Squad of deadly goons
without them knowing but to do it she
has to use every trick she knows what
you might not notice at first is that
the opening action sequence has Stone
showing off just about every skill
she'll need in crucial moments later in
the film Beyond her expert Marksmanship
her talent for hacking and hand-to-hand
combat skills Stone also proves to be a
trained motorcycle rider stealing a bike
from a passerby she also displays her
prowess with a parachute when she swipes
a snow-bound paraglider from a pair of
skiers and uses it to jump off a cliff
these skills all come in handy later
including in a high-flying Escape where
she's forced to use one parachute to
save herself and Kaya Stone also engages
in a thrilling bike Chase when she's
racing to stop Parker in the film's
climax and gets to flaunt more mid-air
moves when she intercepts Parker with a
wing suit in the sky
Heart of Stone definitely likes teasing
the big set pieces early on the opening
credit sequence is one of the most
impressive moments in the entire film
and in addition to paying tribute
visually to genre Classics like
Goldfinger and Thunderball it also pays
tribute to the classics by Thriller
Trope of previewing the movie's big
action sequences just like those
examples the animated opening credits of
Heart of Stone subtly foreshadows some
of the film's biggest moments during the
credits we're given glimpses of Stone's
motorcycle chase through the snowy
mountains as she's pursued by A Deadly
Assassin as well as a hint of her
heart-stopping Escape off a cliff and
into a lagoon an image of stone falling
from the sky foretells her fall from the
heart blend these details might not mean
much on their own but they are a fun
clever way of setting up the movie that
makes a second watch all the more
enjoyable
spy movies are one of the action genre's
oldest Staples so Heart of Stone is
certainly nothing new from Mission
Impossible to the Bourne movies they've
continued to soar in popularity in
recent years too but Heart of Stone
seems to be aiming for a certain energy
and tone similar to the franchise that
defined the format James Bond while
007's agency MI6 is a real-life
intelligence organization the bond
version operates much more closely to
the one scene in Heart of Stone a
shadowy elite group of agents who boast
bleeding edge and indeed futuristic
technology and gadgets I'm undercover
this is just part of it
everything's under control the film's
Striking opening credit sequence with
bold animation and a pop song also
recalls Bond movies even the incidental
score with its emphasis on Horns feels
very Bond the Agents of the charter
meanwhile are also given secretive code
designations but rather than numbers
like 007 their designations are the
numbers and suits in a deck of playing
cards
with Superstar Gal Gadot and the title
role as Rachel Stone a tough as Nails
hero out to save the world from
diabolical villains Heart of Stone has
one obvious connection to DC's Wonder
Woman movies but the film also has one
more connection to DC's greatest female
hero that you might not have noticed a
close look at the film's credits reveals
that the movie was written and produced
by Greg Rucka movie Buffs May recognize
the name for his work on other
female-led action movies like Charlize
Theron's the Old Guard and Kate
beckinsale's whiteout but Rucka is
arguably better known for his work in
the comic book industry including a pair
of iconic runs on DC's Wonder Woman
alongside artist JG Jones Rucka penned
Wonder Woman the hikittea where Diana is
forced into a showdown with Batman not
long after Rucka became the writer on
DC's primary Wonder Woman title on which
he remained for several years
at the Heart of Heart of Stone is swell
the heart a shockingly advanced
artificial intelligence it's the very
core of the charter the worldwide agency
that few know exists thanks to its
highly secretive Quantum Computing code
the heart is able to hack into any
computer system in the world with that
ability it has access to untold amounts
of information that allow it to serve as
a predictive model of everything from an
individual's Behavior to the collapse of
nations with astonishing accuracy the
heart helps guide the charter in its
mission to make the world a better place
in the final moments of the film though
Rachel Stone reveals that they can't
rely on it alone because it's not as
perfect as it's made out to be and for
those paying attention this reveal is
actually alluded to very early in the
film during Stone's daring first mission
in the mountains the heart predicts that
there is no way for her to accomplish
her task after her parachute is stuck on
a cable chance of success just plummeted
only because you've got no imagination
[Music]
Stone says the
is the creativity something she uses to
change the odds it's a brief moment but
one that underscores that the ai's
supposedly perfect algorithms have some
pretty obvious weaknesses and human
assets like Stone are more important
than ever
when we first meet Rachel Stone we are
led to believe that she's a Meek
computer expert and MI6 agent with no
experience in the field but almost
immediately we realize that she's
actually one of the most dangerous and
Elite secret agents in the world we also
learned that in the organization She's
Not Just agent Rachel Stone but she also
goes by the code name nine of Hearts as
we are told more about the charter we
learned that the group is based on a
deck of standard playing cards with four
suits diamonds Hearts Spades and clubs
each commanding a different arm of the
organization each suit has its own group
of Agents but what you might not realize
is that if the Charter's agents are all
named after cards in a deck it means
there can only be 52 total agents that
includes the king of each suit who
operates as the leader of each group we
also meet administrative agent Jack the
man who operates the heart who the
closing credits reveal is actually the
Jack of Hearts it's a fun system but the
format of naming everyone after playing
cards seriously limits the number of
Agents they can have this causes a
problem when Stone recruits Kea at the
end of the film and she's forced to name
her Joker in the First Act audiences are
introduced to a team of dedicated MI6
agents the British super spies are led
by agent Parker whose team includes
Point man Bailey and cold-blooded
Sharpshooter Yang alongside gadot's
computer expert Rachel Stone during
their mission the friendly team members
are frequently seen bickering over what
music they're listening to and it seems
the filmmakers were careful to select
choices for each one that matched up
with their personality the fun-loving
wisecracking Bailey is a big fan of 80s
music he's heard playing the hit 1987
Fleetwood Mac tune everywhere from their
album Tango in the night and
appropriately playful selection
she has the same taste of music and you
have the same hair when Yang has her say
though the tongue shifts to lizzo's
juice a vibrant fast-paced modern pop
song with SAS which perfectly fits her
strong gung-ho attitude and exuberant
energy even when she's blowing away the
baddies Parker meanwhile a
straight-laced Suave Man of Mystery
prefers something more cultured and
old-fashioned his song of choice
Otto Portuguese is a 1960 song that
actually might mean more than you think
in the context of the film when it comes
to Parker who is eventually revealed as
the True Villain of the film his own
choice of Music could actually be seen
as a hint that he's really the hidden
Mastermind and the Very enemy that the
charter is searching for written by
Amalia Rodriguez Fado Portuguese is
taken from her album of the same name
the photo musical genre meanwhile hails
largely from Lisbon Portugal in the
1820s those who have seen Heart of Stone
will already understand the significance
of that location because it's where the
elusive Kea the young woman allied with
Parker in his scheme to steal the heart
is located when the charter tracks her
down in fact they're in Lisbon when he
plays the song suggesting he may have
picked it to fit in but his familiarity
with it may be a clue that he's listened
to it before it's called culture we're
not sure if the choice of song is a Sly
Hint by the filmmakers to plant the seed
for Parker's betrayal but it certainly
seems suspicious in hindsight while the
film centers on agent Rachel Stone we
are also introduced to the four leaders
of the different suits who run the
charter the King of Hearts the King of
Clubs the king of diamonds and the King
of Spades all four kings in the same
room how long has it been three years
not long enough the film makes it clear
that these are the people who make the
big decisions but what audiences may not
notice is a detail hidden in the kings
that isn't readily apparent pay close
attention during the movie and you'll
realize that each suit represents a
different Global superpower King of
Diamonds is the United States King of
Clubs is China King of Spades is Russia
and King of Hearts is the United Kingdom
diffusing a potential international
incident in the South China Sea
and diamonds team is handling hackers
targeting a North American power grid
though they are from
our friend doesn't mean that they don't
have their issues with one another as
there
during their brief meeting in the film
[Music]